est-ce que ce gouvernement penche
effectivement à droite on parle de
Madame Vautrin on parle de Madame Dati
on parle de beaucoup d'anciens
sarkozistes qui sont présents dans cette
équipe est-ce qu'effectivement il il
pensent plutôt à droite ce qui est
intéressant c'est de poser la question
au français déjà effectivement s'ils ont
le sentiment que ce gouvernement penche
plutôt à droite et la semaine dernière
alors évidemment les choses bougent
assez vite et notamment avec les
nombreux commentaires politiques qui a
pu y avoir depuis une semaine mais en
tout cas la semaine dernière quand on
demande aux Français si Gabriel était
àal était plutôt de droite ou plutôt de
gauche ben en fait on se rendit compte
que les gens ne ne savaient absolument
pas le positionner sur les chiquier
politiques il il est situé plutôt au
centre c'est ce qu'on voit aussi
d'ailleurs sur sa côte de popularité on
voit dans les différentes données que
nous avons notamment dans Le barromètre
Figaro Magazine que c'est autant des
gens de droite que de gauche qui
l'apprécie et qui souhaite
qu'il qui apprécie Gabriel Atal c'estàd
qu'il a une certaine plasticité je
dirais dans l'opinion que soit auprès
des sympathisants de gauche ou des
sympathisants de droite donc euh à
savoir si au final ce gouvernement est
de droit je crois que ça va dépendre
aussi surtout des projets et euh des
différents voilà des différents dossiers
qui sont menés et je crois que c'est ce
que les Français attend notamment c'est
de savoir quelle va être un petit peu la
ligne politique et les les les grands
projets il y a notamment la question du
pouvoir d'achat qui reste quand même la
première préoccupation euh des Français
de loin de très loin euh la deuxième
c'est la santé et ensuite la sécurité
mais vous voyez la première
préoccupation c'est vraiment le pouvoir
d'achat et là en terme de politique à
mener que ce soit à gauche ou à droite
effectivement il y a un certain nombre
de de choses qui peuvent être FA et on
va voir très vite effectivement si
c'était plutôt un gouvernement de droite
de centre- droit ou autre Carl il y a
quand même une chose qui est flagrante
quand on regarde les noms on avait on a
un peu l'impression parfois d'être en
2007 quoi quand Nicolas Sarkozi est
arrivé au pouvoir c'est vrai qu'il y a
beaucoup de de de
de alors en plus avec cette je sais pas
s'il faut appeler cette arrivée ou ce
symbole que représente Rachid hadti qui
a fait couler beaucoup d'ancre
évidemment il a fait l'ouverture
jusqu'au sarkoziste ce qui était ce que
réclamait Patrick de vedjan en 2007 vous
vous souvenez parce qu'il rallait qui a
trop d'ouverture et qui est pas assé de
Sarkozy non pour répondre à votre
question oui c'est un gouvernement de
droite mais ça na ça n'est pas
surprenant parce que
aujourd'huière quand vous êtes de gauche
politique de gauche est-ce que vous
allez dans gouvernement est-ce que vous
allez avec Emmanuel Macron après le vote
de la loi immigration bien sûr que non
et donc la source de la gauche c'est try
pour Emmanuel Macron en revanche la
source des politiques de droite continue
à à l'alimenter pour la raison
d'ailleurs inverse c'est un parce qu'il
y a eu ce projet de loi immigration
parce qu'il y a eu je vais y revenir ce
qu'a fait Gabriel etal sur l'éducation
et surtout ça on dit aussi très long sur
l'avenir des LR c'est-à-dire que en fait
ces personnalités
qui soit sont restés qui éit parti
depuis 2017 pour la plupart soit arrivve
aujourd'hui comme rachelti ça en don sur
ce qu'elle estime être l'avenir
politique deslr en gros si on si on
quitte le navire pour pour aller voir
Emmanuel Macron et parer chez LR c'est
qu'on on Nimagine pas que les LR ont ont
un grand avenir et dernière élément
effectivement si Gabriel Atal continue à
matigon ce qu'il a fait à l'éducation
nationale
c'est encore plus un gouvernement qui va
séduire l'électorat droite parce que ce
qu'on a remarqué grâce aux données de de
verriant dans le baromètre c'est qu'en
fait le décollage de Gabriel Atal dans
le l'opinion se fait à partir du moment
où il est à l'éducation nationale et où
il prend ses positions sur la laïcité
contre la BAA et ça ça plaît à l'élector
à droite donc là on va voir il est un
peu sous surveillance gabrielal d'accord
Louis euh alors effectivement ça peut
avoir des conséquences pour le parti LR
est-ce que alors je sais pas si la seule
personnalité de Rachid hadti mais quand
même elle a une importance est-ce que ça
peut faire en sorte qu'effectivement ça
vienne renforcer la majorité
présidentielle avec des députés qui
viennent de la droite LR et que ça
affaiblisse du coup le groupe de
Monsieur marlex alors je n'y crois pas
ou alors à la marche parce que je pense
que les les LR les députés LR en tout
cas qui devaient passer chez Macron je
pense que c'est déjà fait maintenant il
y a plus grand monde à prendre alors il
y a dans dans le groupe LR qui compte
une soixantaine de membres il y en a
encore quelques-uns qui se verrai bien
si on leur donne des postes si on venait
vers eux participer à l'aventure
macroniste mais ça fait depuis 2017
qu'Emmanuel Macron braque la banque à
l'air en allant chercher maintenant dans
tous les coins pour aller soit achever
les les survivants soit surtout leur
leur dire venez avec moi c'est c'est là
que ça se passe donc ça met l'air
évidemment dans une une une situation
délicate mais ça fait aussi qu'il est
allé un peu au bout du processus c'est
vrai que Rashid Dati et c'est pour ça
qu'il a eu un effet de surprise ça
restait une des des grandes figures à à
prendre surtout quand on souvient de ces
critiques contre le le macronisme qui
sont ressortis immédiatement après sa
nomination et qu' on regarde la semaine
dernière en fait ce qu'il faut voir il y
a quand même il y a deux il y a deux
surprises c'est Gabriel ATA le Premier
ministre parce que franchement son nom
n'était pas dans les favoris ne sa que
quelques jours quelques heures avant
dans son jeune âge notamment oui et puis
le fait que Emmanuel Macron pour la
première fois choisissent quelqu'un de
connu de politique là où il avait choisi
des premier ministres au profil de
collaborateur
ou de directeur de cabinet inconnu des
Français qui ne pouvait pas lui faire de
l'ombre or là on voit que Gabriel Atal
pur produit du macronisme peut faire de
l'ombre et va peut-être en faire dans
une certaine mesure à son à son mentor
et puis l'autre surprise quelques jours
plus tard bah c'est rachidti et en fait
ça vient ça vient masquer la la l'assez
grande stabilité finalement des
équilibres de ce gouvernement les poids
lourds sont toujours là Bruno le au même
poste Gérald daran au même poste éc
Dupont morti au même poste les grands
périmètres restent les mêmes même si on
a uer quelques ministres comme celui de
la la fonction publique par exemple pour
donner voilà pour donner l'impression
cette image de gouvernement resserré
mais en fait les les voilà les les
grands postes avec les mêmes titulaires
sont toujours là mais ce qui est venu
masquer cette stabilité c'est évidemment
la nomination de Gabriel Atal et puis la
la surprise du chef Rachid adati qui
évidemment crée un effet dans l'opinion
publique parce que les gens la
connaissent et qui crée une déflagration
chez LR parce que bah Dati c'est
quelqu'un chez les républicains erti a
été a été furieux
c'est ouis c'est la star des
républicains et puis même chez elle
était pas du tout à la marge elle était
courtisée ericotti lui a proposé la tête
de liste des des européennes elle a
refusé donc ou présidente du Conseil
national il lui a donné elle lui a donné
des titres au niveau des instances
interne donc c'est quand même un un
énorme choc supplémentaire à absorber
pour enfin sortie des LR et exclusion
immédiate prononcé par le par le chef
instantanément bon je pense que ça
l'opinion publique s'en fiche un peu de
qui est dans quel
sur avait don son discours étaite
autonomisé par rapport au républainisait
pas les fiches de la ligne du parti
c'est pas le genre c'est pas son genre à
elle et comme son objectif était et
reste la mairie de Paris elle tient un
discours qui est plus en adéquation avec
l'électorat qu'elle vise très parisien
pour déloger àidalgo en 2026 ça reste
son premier objectif politique quand
même alors Paul on sait que le premier
ministre
veut s'adresser aux classes
moyenn faisant ainsi on voit bien qu'il
veut chasser sur les terres c'est normal
de du rassemblement national qui est qui
sont pour beaucoup des classes moyennes
sont attirés quand même par le vote du
rassemblement national il a rendu
hommage un hommage très appuyé à Jean
Castex qui est aussi un peu ce côté
homme du terroir un peu l'antithèse
d'ailleurs du du de hatal et d'une
certaine façon Rachid adati c'est une
arme Antin aussi antien non il en tout
cas ce qui est certain c'est que au RN
ils ont compris la menace ils ont vu àal
la nomination àal comme une menace d'où
l'interview la double interview qui a
été donné ce weekend au JDD est-ce que
Atal est capable d'aller
euh désorganiser la force électorale de
Marine Le Pen qu'elle construit
patiemment en vue 2027 là on voit bien
que en fait quand on regarde précisément
les sondages pour les européennes et bah
euh elle commence à toucher des classes
sociales qu'elle ne touchait pas avant
comme les retraités les seniors des gens
plus aisés elle est en train lisser un
peu son son socle électoral et et
peut-être que c'est aussi l'idée
d'Emmanuel Macron d'instaurer un
gouvernement qui fera une campagne
électorale en vue des européennes et
d'avoir Atal à matigon pour ça euh
est-ce qu'il y arrivera c'est la grande
question ils ont observé au RN les les 5
mois de Gabriel hatal à l'éducation
nationale et ils ont été assez perturbés
parce que oui parce que hatal il a bondi
dans les sondages en reprenant un petit
peu parfois des positions alors
quiestiment être des positions du RN
mais qui é un peu des positions aussi
que les Français voulaient c'estàd une
une d'êre sur fermeté sur la licité sur
la BAA sur le résultat scolaire sur
l'autorité à l'école c'est ce que
veulent les Français aussi et donc
Gabriel quand il arrive il déroule le
bulldoer il propose tout ça il veut
mettre en action tout ça donc il a pas
le temps de le faire finalement parce
qu'il passe à matigon il est nommé mais
au RN ils sont ils ont été assez
désarcenés parce que voilà un ministre
qui leur parle gentiment qui leur dit je
pense que sur certaines propositions
vous avez peut-être raison et qu'il faut
écouter les Français qui reprend
quelques propositions du rassemblement
national et qui on dans les sondages du
coup est-ce qu'il y a pas un boulevard
pour le Gabriel Atal d'aller en tout cas
mettre un coin dans les classes moyenne
et les actifs qui votent en majorité
Marine Le Pen aujourd'hui et d'aller la
raccrocher au macronisme alors on va
écouter vous allez voir Raphael Luxman
qui lui pense effectivement que c'est un
gouvernement de droite vous allez voir
il y a pas tellement de doute là-dessus
pour lui les macronistes passent leur
temps à parler de dépassement et bien là
on a le dépassement du macronisme dans
le sarkosisme et cette liste de
ministres c'est un signal extrêmement
clair qui est envoyé enfin c'est ce
gouvernement est de droite et de droite
et donc la poque non il reste quelques
personnalités de gauche quand même la
politique à tous les minist à tous les
ministères régaliens ce sont des des
gens de LR en réalité qui sont au au
pouvoir et aux manettes j'ai pas
l'impression que ce soit un gouvernement
de droite moi je le dis encore une fois
et vous l'avez très justement dit de
votre introduction nous sommes unis et
derrière un homme qui s'appelle Emmanuel
Macron je pense que ce qui nous a uni
depuis le début et qui continue à
rallier des personnalités engagées des
acteur politique c'est cette volonté
d'agir d'agir de façon pragmatique dans
un pays qui évolue extrêmement vite au
regard du contexte qui est le nôre alors
quand Raphaël gluspan dit c'est un
gouvernement et de droite et de droite
il fait référence à François vteran à
qui on demandait la définition du centre
et disait le centre c'est et de droite
et de droite euh lors Salvin
est-ce
que on a l'impression aussi que c'est un
peu l'opération de la dernière chance
pour Emmanuel Macron je me trompe ou pas
de de frapper l'opinion il peut plus se
représenter en 2027 ça on l'a répété on
le sait mais quand même il doit laisser
une trace et puis la France en bon ordre
et puis et puis ne pas céder le pouvoir
à Marine Le Pen pr certain ce qui est
certain effectivement c'est que là il a
vraiment voulu un peu changer de cap je
pense qu'on en SAA certainement
davantage aussi demain mais là en
nommant un premier ministre
effectivement qui n'est pas un
gestionnaire en prenant qui n'est pas un
technicien alors que précédemment c'est
plutôt ce qu'il nous ce qu'il avait
l'habitude de faire en prenant des
ministres aussi star parce que on
parlait de Rachid hadti c'est une
ministre très populaire auprès des
électeurs de droite mais c'est aussi une
ministre très populaire je dirais
au-delà enfin voilà c'est toamment quand
on va enfin ça m'est arrivé d'aller en
banlieu avec elle c'est que vous allez
en banlieu en province dans des petites
villes et cetera elle elle lumière elle
attire la lumière elle elle laisse pas
en tout cas indifférent elle peut être
détestée ou adorée elle a un petit côté
quand même assez fascinant d'ailleurs
hein de femmes politiques courageuses et
cetera donc effectivement il il a le on
a le sentiment que il souhaite montrer
autre chose et que il met plutôt en en
place un gouvernement euh je dirais
presque guerrier voyez il veut aller à
la confrontation électorale on a a une
grosse échéance là et c'est une grosse
échéance pour lui notamment les
élections européennes de cette année
c'est vrai que pour le moment encore en
France on en parle pas trop les Français
sont pas très intéressés encore par ces
par ces élections mais pour lui ce sont
des élections capital et notamment
peut-être pour l'après aussi il faut
qu'il arrive à montrer qu'il est capable
de faire quelque chose pendant ses ses
élections européennes donc c'est
effectivement alors je dirais pas que
c'est la dernière chance parce que il y
a quand même il reste encore un petit
peu de temps dans son mandat mais en
tout cas il a voulu effectivement
marquer une une une différence qui ne se
voit pas encore dans l'opinion je dirais
quand même parce que quand vous demandez
au français est-ce que ce nouveau
gouvernement va signer un un
renouvellement en tout cas dans la
politique et dans la façon de faire de
la politique pour le moment les Français
n'y croient pas vraiment ils sont plutôt
assez blasés ils ont plutôt le sentiment
que ça va être en fait finalement comme
précédemment avec Emmanuel Macron qui
surtout prend des décisions et les
ministres et premier ministr suivent et
et appliquent donc on est plutôt
là-dedans mais effectivement malgré tout
il donne des signes Emmanuel Macron d'un
changement peut-être de méthode aussi
hein et peut-être que gabrielal va être
beaucoup plus en avant que l'on étai les
précédents premier ministres de Macron
on peut le croire ça Carle en tout cas
c'est ce que on nous dit à l'Élysée ah
oui et quand on regarde quand même ce
qui s'est passé une fonctionnement
gaulien alors avec on revient alors le
le duo qui est pris en exemple c'est de
Gaul Pompidou ouis c'est ça ouais donc
c'est quand on nous dit ça à l'Élysée je
pense ô nous les interlocuteurs on est
assez dubitatif parce que le
fonctionnement d'Emmanuel Macron depuis
2017 c'était pas ça tout le contraire
c'était tout le contraire c'était bah
Sarkozy ou ou Macron et en gros les
collaborateurs là de GA le pompinou ça
veut dire que il va laisser une marge de
manœuvre assez grande à son premier
ministre et on est même dans l'idée
d'une transmission et c'est en ça
finalement que ce qui s'est passé la
semaine dernière est une vraie rupture
mais et à tous les points de vue rupture
générationnelle on l'a dit d'accord mais
rupture d'Emmanuel Macron avec ses
alliés en 2022 à l'issue de la séquence
électorale Emmanuel Macron veut nommer
Catherine Vautrin à matigon qui vient de
la droite aussi qui vient de la droite
c'est quasiment fait elle a téléphoné à
Jean Castex tout tout est prêt mais
voilà c'est sans compter sans Richard
Ferrand et François Baayou qui prennent
leur téléphone qui disent à tu peux pas
nommer quelqu'un qui était antiariage
pour tous qui a des positions c'est la
droite Sarkozy et Emmanuel Macron fait
Mar machine arrière et et prend le plan
B ellizabeth borne cette fois-ci il se
passe à peu près la même chose toute
proportion
gardé on sait que Richard Ferrand et
François baayrou avaient d'autres noms
en tête Juli Normandie Sébastien Lecornu
et quand il voit arriver le nom de
Gabriel Atal bah ils refont la même
chose ils se disent ça marcher une
première fois ça devrait marcher une
deuxième fois on va dire à Emmanuel
Macron tu peux pas faire ça et il va
nous suivre mais non là non seulement il
a pas suivi mais il les a pas écouté
puisque derrière en plus il nomme un
gouvernement où François Baayou retrouve
pas les petit deuxème rupture qui est
assez intéressante et la troisème
rupture c'est c'est par rapport à
lui-même c'est-à-dire qu'on avait un
Emmanuel Macron qui voulait s'occuper
tout qui qui considérait que le premier
ministre était un collaborateur là
semble prêt je dis bien semble prêt
parce qu'il va
falloir voir dans les faits à être en
retrait par rapport à gabrielatal ou
tout au moins dans un rôle qui sera
différent et donc c'est en ça qu'il y a
effectivement une rupture néanmoins il
va prendre la parole avant le discours
de politique généraleou c'est pour ça
que on n pas encore à de GA pompidout
même si c'est effectivement ce qu'on
essaie de nous vendre avec cette
conception très gaulienne alors on nous
dit aussi que la conférence de presse de
demain soir et aussi une réactivation de
l'imaginaire gaulien parce que c'est un
des exercices favoris du général de
Gaulle que de convoquer la presse pour
de longues conférences de presse où il
faisait il faisait tout son numéro et on
on se souvient de célèbres tirad mais
quand même le fait euh déjà d'imposer de
lui-même composer la plupart du
gouvernement parce que tous les tous les
grands choix de ce gouvernement sont
ceux d'Emmanuel Macron la pas de Gabriel
Atal c'est Aurore berger qui finalement
est sauvé en tant que ministre délégué
c'est Marie Lebec au relation avec le
Parlement c'est pris CATV au
porte-parole enfin voilà c'est des gens
que le grand public ne connaît pas et le
choix par exemple de maintenir Bron le
mer et géraldmanin bah c'est c'est
Emmanuel Macron lui-même et
effectivement le discours de politique
générale de de Gabriel Attal est attendu
la semaine prochaine mais en fait
Emmanuel Macron fait une conférence de
presse à l'horaire du prime time des des
télévisions donc ça veut bien dire qu'
il veut il continue à être dans la
logique où celui qu'on doit écouter et
ben c'est d'abord lui et c'est lui qui
qui donne le cap est-ce que ce
gouvernement parce qu'il fait appel donc
à un premier ministre très politique
beaucoup plus que les précédents à à des
professionnels de la politique quelque
part Catherine vaterin Rachid hadti même
Stéphane séjourné qui est président du
parti présidentiel et qui est toujours
dans les les arrangements politiciens
qui devient ministre des Affaires é
voilà on n pas on est plus dans le
gouvernement des techniciens la société
civile c'est fini hein là on en entend
plus du tout plus du tout parler alors
est-ce que c'est pour faire la campagne
des européennes ça c'est ce que disent
beaucoup dans la majorité en disant que
c'est un gouvernement de combat pour les
européennes qui d'ailleurs à le changer
à nouveau après les élections
européennes ou après les Jeux Olympiques
quand on sera rentré dans dans une
nouvelle phase voilà c'est possible
après il va falloir vendre aussi enfin
il va falloir expliquer le fait que ce
gouvernement est donc plus là pour faire
campagne et pour marquer l'opinion et
les médias que pour faire faire avancer
des dossiers pour faire avancer des
réformes Emmanuel Macron va sans doute
le clarifier peut-être demain mais pour
l'instant il y a pas beaucoup de textes
législatifs dans les les tuyaux
parlementaires la réforme des retraites
ça a été fait la loi immigration ça a
été fait dans la douleur mais ça a quand
même été fait au mois de décembre en
fait les les réformes promises par
Emmanuel Macron sont plutôt engagé
maintenant l'enjeu c'est les résultats
c'est l'effet que ça produit ou pas aux
yeux des Français et c'est aussi ce qui
estvolu à travers ce gouvernement c'est
en fait c'est peut-être même moins
d'agir que de marquer d'expliquer de
cranter le
face aux adversaires et je ne sais pas
si vous vous souvenez de ce ce moment où
Emmanuel Macron avait dit à sa majorité
soyez fier d'être des amateurs c'était
son premier quinen bon bah là il
s'aperçu que les professionnels c'était
pas mal ai finalement pour faire de la
politiqueis alors justement alors on va
se poser la question de savoir qu'est-ce
qui doit dire demain parce que ça c'est
la grande question qu'est-ce qui va
normalement la la conférence de presse
va durer quelques 2 heures je
crois une heure de grande écoute euh il
y a la Chevauchée des SEP mercenaires
sur une autre chaîne ah demain donc ça
va être compliqué qu'est-ce que à votre
avis il doit euh doit direà Emmanuel
Macron il nous avait donné rendez-vous
il avait donné un rendez-vous oui
rendez-v la nation alors ça se
transforme en rendez-vous avec les
journalistes euh mais bon à la télé
devant plusieurs millions de Français
euh il avait aussi des mots attachés à
ce rendez-vouslà réarmement civique
c'est ça nation ouais euh parce que
rendez-vous avec la nation donc il avait
toute une idée derrière alors Mo je suis
pas l'exécutif comme luoui mais il y
avait toute une idée derrière en tout
cas d'aller d'avoir une parole
présidentielle sur des thèmes
particulier de la société d'attendre des
Français de la sur la société sûrement à
l'école sûrement sur la sécurité et
peut-être une continuité par rapport
aussi à la loi immigration qui a quand
même cranté dans un électorat qui a
marqué en tout cas son quinquena dans la
page n pas tout à fait tourné d'ailleurs
n'est pas tout à fait tourné on attend
des décisions du Conseil constitutionnel
qui vont peut-être rebattre les cartes
donc il va peut-être avir d'autres aller
retour législatif là-dessus euh donc il
avait on avait en tout cas il donnait
cette idée- làà que l'année 2024 en vue
des européennes et même pour le le euh
le second quinquena elle a être
marqué avec une certaine saveur en tout
cas il avoir une certaine saveur
présidentielle aujourd'hui euh on est
peu peut-être un peu perturbé parce que
avec un remanimement d'ampleur un
nouveau Premier ministre une nouvelle
impulsion politique peut-être un
gouvernement très très politique
peut-être le plus politique que Emmanuel
Macron n''est jamais eu euh qui
peut-être lui correspond peut-être le
mieux d'ailleurs au final euh parce
qu'il y a vraiment que des proches que
euh en tout cas Gabriel un très proche
euh voilà donc euh il va devoir
expliquer quand même aussi ple de choses
qu'est-ce qui donne comme objectif pour
les européennes par exemple aussi à la
liste Renaissance l deux questions
est-ce que c'est une une intervention
qui est très attendue par les Français
et le choix de cette conférence de
presse à cette heure-là sous cette forme
là qu'est-ce que vous en pensez bah
alors déjà c'est vrai qu'il y a quand
même une ambigué est-ce que c'est
vraiment le grand rendez-vous qu'il
avait donné aux Français mais nul ne le
sait en fait parce que on parce qu'on se
dit est-ce que le grand rendez-vous avec
la nation est-ce qu'il a pas été scandé
en plusieurs si c'est le coup d'envoie
de ce rendez-vous et ça c'est ce qu'on
dit à l'Élysée maintenant d'cord ok
parce que je suis pas sûr que que les
Français le décodent comme ça c'est pour
le moment c'est ils ont oublié le grand
rendez-vous bah non ils s'attendent à
autre chose parce que un grand
rendez-vous avec les Français c'est pas
effectivement une conférence de presse
avec des journalistes pendant 2hures on
a on a on a l'habitude effectivement de
ça donc déjà je suis pas sûr que ce soit
identifié comme ça mais peut-être que
d'ici demain ça sera clarifié d'accord
euh voilà est-ce qu'il l'attendent bah
il vient quand même déjà de parler il a
fait ses vœux il y a pas très longtemps
le président donc à part si c'est
vraiment pour dire quelque chose de
différent sinon je pense que les
Français non n'attendent absolument rien
ce qu'ils attendent les Français
aujourd'hui c'est de clarifier peut-être
le sens donné à ce nouveau gouvernement
et la nouvelle impulsion s'il y a une
nouvelle impulsion je crois que on a
encore aujourd'hui un déficit de sens
donneré à ce qu'on fait et ce que font
les hommes politiques et les femmes
politiques quand quand ils font un
certain nombre de choses Édouard
Philippe l'a remarqué la semaine
dernière en disant c'est bizarre il me
semblait qu'on changeait de Premier
ministre uniquement quand on change
changer de cap ou de politique là je ne
vois ni changement de cap ni changement
de politique bon c'est vrai que pour le
moment on a beaucoup commenté la
jeunesse du Premier ministre la
proximité le côté courageux volontaire
et cetera mais on sait pas vraiment ce
qu'il quelle est sa feuille de route en
fait et je pense que s'il y a quelque
chose qu'on attend demain en tout cas
que les Français attendent demain c'est
clarifier justement pourquoi on close
cette séquence entre guillemets de
technicien born et cetera et qu'est-ce
qu'on veut faire avec un un gouvernement
aussi politique et plus resserré aussi
alors écoutez Sébastien ch lui il a une
idée très précise il attend
rien écoutez moi ce que j'attends parce
que je je vais pas commenter des des des
exercices de communication ce que
j'attends comme je pense une grande
partie de la population française c'est
que le Président de la République
s'attaque enfin aux problématiques qui
frappent aujourd'hui les Français et à
leur première priorité la première de
ces priorités aujourd'hui c'est la
question du pouvoir d'achat c'est la
question des prix donc voilà ce que
j'attends que le Président de la
République nous fasse enfin des annonces
concrètes qu'on sorte de sous cette
séquence de communication et qu'on nous
dise maintenant qu'est-ce qui va être
fait pour que les Français leur vie soit
moins difficile le président de la
République nous a déjà habitué à ces
formats ce qu'on nous dit c'est une
conférence de presse XXL àe superlatif
qui à la fin ne débouche sur rien moi je
me souviens et je garde un mauvais
souvenir des débats des gilets jaunes on
disait c'est des heures de débat il a
parlé de tout et à la fin que reste-t-il
de tout cela rien donc non nous
n'attendons rien mais je crois que les
Français n'attendent pas grand-chose du
président de la République alors Louis
vous qui êtes dans les petits papiers de
quoi on va parler demain à votre avis on
va parler en fait comme c'est
effectivement le début du fameux
rendez-vous avec la la nation mais qui
effectivement commence surtout par les
journalistes avant de commencer avec la
nation comme l'a dit Paul euh il veut
parler de l'école ça c'est une certitude
alors est-ce que est-ce qu'il met
vraiment l'accent dès demain là-dessus
ou est-ce qu'il y a d'autres séquences
comme on dit dans le jargon des
communiquants ensuite ça je ne sais pas
encore le découpage mais en tout cas il
a envie pour sa rentrée de de placer
l'école au cœur de ses priorités et sous
le prisme de l'autorité et ça ça rejoint
des arbitrages qui sont dans les tuyau
depuis longtemps sur deux points majeurs
déjà l'uniforme alors on sait qu' une
expérimentation de l'uniforme à l'école
commence avec les collectivités qui sont
volontaires on le sait c'est juste ça
n'a pas été formalisé personne ne
l'aannoncé Gabriel hatal n'a pas pu
l'annoncé quand il était ministre de
l'Éducation et il était question
qu'Emmanuel Macron l'annonce lui-même
pour donner un caractère présidentiel à
cette annonce qui encore une fois n'est
pas le le l'arrivée de l'uniforme
partout à l'école mais des
expérimentations au cas par cas dans
certains établissements et puis il y a
le le fameux SNU le service national
universel alors ça c'est pareil ça
traîne depuis des années parce que ça
s'appelle universel mais en fait c'est
pas du tout universel ça concerne que
quelques milliers de de jeunes chaque
année à ce stade donc on là aussi on est
dans le registre de l'expérimentation et
Emmanuel Macron depuis des années doit
rendre un arbitrage pour dire si il le
généralise c'est est-ce que ça devient
vraiment universel est-ce que c'est le
retour d'un service national comme
l'était le service militaire pour toute
une classe d'âge toute une génération
voilà ça c'était des discussions qui
étaient présentes en amont qui tourne
depuis longtemps quand il s'agit du
sujet de l'école de la jeunesse de de
l'autorité de l'éducation civique et
morale et qui pourrait trouver leur
place dans ce dans ce rendez-vous avec
la nation après c'est une conférence de
presse donc les journalistes posent des
questions là on aura le droit donc il va
nécessairement aborder tous les sujets
en tout cas tous les sujets qui lui
seront soumis tous les sujets
d'actualité et l'autre sujet sur lequel
il veut aller assez fort en ce début
d'année c'est l'économie c'est
poursuivre les réformes c'est la
simplification et faire une une sorte de
de loi Macron 2 quelque part c'estd
conserver le même esprit de
libéralisation et simplification de
certains secteurs économiques ça aussi
c'était dans les idées qu'il avait en
tête pour ce début d'année alors pour
parler un peu cuisine racontez-nous
comment ça se passe d'ailleurs ce genre
de conférence de presse c'est pas le
journaliste qui pose une question comme
ça il a il s'est d'abord inscrit sur un
registre comment ça se passe alors la
dernière fois non c'est c'est moins
organisé que ce qu'on peut peut penser
comme très souvent en politique
d'ailleurs quand on croit qu'il y a des
grands complots organisés en fait en
fait non souvent c'est c'est beaucoup de
choses sont improvisé les souvenirs que
j'ai des des deux dernières conférences
de presse parce qu'Emmanuel Macron nen a
pas fait tant que ça en fait il a fait
les gilets jaunes en 2019 il en a fait
une avant la présidence française de
l'Union européenne c'était avant la
campagne de de 2022 et puis en
présentant son programme en 2022 mais là
il était plus candidat que Président il
avait fait aussi une conférence de
presse non il fallait pas spécialement
s'inscrire il fallait se battre un petit
peu pour pouvoir poser une question
alors évidemment le poids du média joue
les personnalités des journalistes
peuvent jouer mais c'est surtout un peu
de voilà de de comment dire on essaie de
demander la parole on essaie de la voir
on essaie d'avoir le micro et puis on
l'a ou pas quoi c'est c'est comme ça
mais c'est vrai qu'il y a souvent plus
de journalistes présent que de questions
posé et pourtant Emmanuel Macron comme
il aime il aime bien parler déjà et puis
il aime bien un petit peu l'exercice
voilà de se confronter aux questions
c'est vrai qu'il faut lu reconnaître
qu'il aime bien un petit peu en tout cas
se confronter à la contradiction pour
pouvoir y répondre et ben c'est souvent
les exercices à rallonge et donc demain
je crains le pire sur l'ordre de la fin
de conférence de presse mais on sea là
jusqu'au bout rassurez-vous Carl Louis
disait l'école alors il y a une des
particularités qu'on a d'ailleurs
souligné quand on a vu monsieur Atal à
leuve c'est que l'école ce qui est
pratique c'est qu'on est on a pas besoin
de passer par la loi là ah bah
complètement quand on n pas de majorité
rel quand on n pas de majorité absolue
oui ça c'est l'un des c'est quand même
plus confortable c'est plus confortable
même si quand on regarde dans le détail
sur la cinquantaine de textes de loi qui
ont été discuté à l'Assemblée nationale
en dehors des retraites et des textes
financiers il y a pas eu de 493 et et
des majorités différentes donc il y a
des voies de passage sont peut-être un
peu plus compliqué cette année mais il y
aura il y aura des voies de passage mais
c'est sûr que l'école le gros avantage
c'est que vous prenez des décisions tout
de suite je prends une circulaire pour
dire que j'interdis la BAA l'uniforme je
fais de l'expérimentation et vous voyez
sur cette idée de d'école on est encore
là dans dans la transmission un
conseiller du président essayer de lui
vendre en décembre l'idée que qu'il soit
le président des générations futures
comme il ne peut pas se représenter
qu'au fond il y ait cette passation de
de flambeau ça tombe bien on est année
des Jeux Olympiques et bientôt il va y
avoir le flambeau qui va passer et que
donc en fait il s'adresse à la jeunesse
et on sait d'ailleurs que le Emmanuel
Macron est plus fort dans les catégories
de retraité là je parle sur le contrôle
de l'or que chez les les jeunes qui qui
av il sont plutôt bah chez Jean
Mélenchon et chez Marine Le Pen en en
grande majorité et donc il faut quand
même qu' voilà il a semble-t-il accepté
de de prendre ce ce passage de flambeau
et de faire cette transmission donc il y
a deux thèmes là je sais pas s'il
l'abordera demain mais il y a
l'éducation et puis il y a la transition
écologique aussi sur lequel il a
toujours beaucoup de mal à cranter les
choses ils ont fait des des choses ils
ont passé des des lois ils ont
euh fermé euh
en Guyane des choses comme ça mais
l'opinion le crédite toujours pas d'être
un un président écolo puis il y a pardon
mais il y a quand même juste il y a
aussi le pouvoir d'achat on en a parlé
tout à l'heure mais dis absolument rien
sur le pouvoir d'achat ça va compliqué
j'allais en parler oui le pouvoir
d'achat alors le pouvoir d'achat le
problème c'est que les ces sont vides
ouais
il y a plus beaucoup d'argent il y a eu
la politique du chèque quand même qui
arrive un peu au bout de sa logique
puisqueque tout le monde en bénéfici pas
et c'est un peu compliqué à voir parfois
et c'est un peu confus pour les gens de
toute façon les gens il regardent
plusurs chososees regard le prix de leur
paniier de quand ils font leur cour le
prix de la viande et le prix de
l'essence et aujourd'hui on est toujours
dans le rouge euh et euh c'est là-dessus
que Martelle beaucoup le rassemblement
national c'est sa campagne et ça sera je
pense sa campagne pour les trois
prochaines années jusqu'à la
présidentielle Marine Le Pen elle a
trouvé son fil en d'or qui est parler du
pouvoir d'achat elle avait commencé 2021
en disant je vais renationaliser les
autoroutes et vendre le public je pense
qu'en 2027 elle refera les mêmes
propositions parce que là ils ont le
filon ils ont trouvé le filon elle-même
vient d'êre êté élu sur une terre du
Nord dans le Pas de calis donc elle-même
a été confrontée ce discours là auprès
de ses électeurs et euh aujourd'hui elle
a réussi à imposer cette ligne là au
sein de son parti qui est devenu
incontestable et donc elle va euh tenter
de de labourer ce terrain là en disant
que c'est la faute de l'Europe c'est les
prix de l'électricité et du gaz sont
aussi haut c'est la faute la faute des
accords de libre échange si les prix
sont aussi forts dans l'alimentation euh
pour l'immigration s' y a d'immigration
ça fait baisser les salaires en fait
elle a toute cette rhtorique là toute
cette politique là et tout ce programme
là son seul problème aujourd'hui c'est
que elle a des mesurettes à l'instanté à
présenter au français baisse de TVA
baisse de taxes à effet limité et que si
elle applique ces mesures là il y a
encore moins d'argent dans la caisse lur
Salvin il va y avoir aussi une question
très vraisemblablement demain on va lui
dire parce que personne n'est dupe
Rashida Dati alors pourquoi vous êtes
allé chercher Rachida Dati est-ce que
vous avez passé un accord pour le gain
de la ville de Paris éventuellement en
2026 euh ou est-ce que vous avez aussi
dans la tête et ben justement de donner
un coup de pied dans la fourmilière du
monde de la culture du l'audiovisuel
publicque où on sait que bah les figures
sont très souvent plutôt à gauche
d'ailleurs hein oui et et et je crois
qu'effectivement si Rachid adati a été
choisi c'est en raison aussi pour sa
tenacité aussi c'est-à-dire que quand
elle est sur un sujet quand
elle exactement quand elle a un projet à
mettre en c'est elle elle elle reste
cramponnée jusqu'à ce qu'elle y arrive
donc al je sais pas si c'est ce qu'il va
répondre ou pas en tout cas c'est ce que
perçoivent les Français clairement la T
la ténacité le courage ce sont des des
qualificatifs qui sont très souvent
accordés à à Rachid Dati ce qui est
intéressant aussi chez Rachid Dati c'est
que même si elle n'est plus sur la scène
politique nationale de premier plan je
dirais depuis plusieurs années malgré
tout elle reste dans l'opinion euh très
très haut ça fait partie vous voyez des
hommes et des femmes politiques on a on
a deux pages dans le B Figaro Magazine
une à droite une à gauche à gauche c'est
la la la page où les hommes et les
femmes politiques sont le plus haut
effectivement elle est dans cette page
de gauche quoi voyez quand on quand on
regarde donc il y a aussi peut-être ça
peut-être que le président va dire aussi
mais moi je voulais aussi des figures
politiques qui me permettent euh bah
peut-être de de euh comment dire d'avoir
une adhésion de l'opinion beaucoup plus
large que ce que j'avais à l'heure
actuelle et pu puis aussi euh ce qui est
intéressant chez Rachid Dati c'est euh
sa clarté de discours c'est-à-dire quand
elle parle les Français comprennent ce
qu'elles disent et effectivement ce qui
a été beaucoup reproché au ministres euh
de aux différents ministres d'Emmanuel
Macron dans le temps c'est cette
technicité c'est ce jargon un petit peu
technique voire technocrate or là elle
est c'est limpide en fait hein quand
elle parle on comprend très clairement
ce qu'elle veut dire il y a pas beaucoup
de non dit euh et c'est c'est peut-être
aussi malgré tout une qualité qu'on
attend aujourd'hui
en politique Gabriel c'est un peu la
même chose c'est très clair il a une
façon très très claire de parler sans
tabou aussi et je pense que c'est c'est
quand il y a cette demande dans
l'opinion de
transparence de dire les choses et
cetera d'authenticité on parle beaucoup
de d'authenticité en politique bah c'est
peut-être ça aussi qu'elle est all qu'il
est allé chercher d'une certaine façon
on peut considérer que madame ou
casterra aussi non oui là enfin on n pas
tous compris ce qu'elle voulait dire
exactement ça c'est plus du du registre
de l'exercice de Come voyez c'est
comment vous vous extirpez d'une d'une
d'une polémique mais il y a d'ailleurs
si on compare aid Dati et Amélie ou
Castera il y a aussi ça c'est les
origines sociales le parcours ça dit
beaucoup aussi c'estd que ça parle en
faveur de de Rachid hadti face à
d'autres ministres on en a vu beaucoup
sur Emmanuel Macron dont on percevait
quand même plus ou moins vaguement
queils avaient pas trop d'idée de ce
qu'était la France des réalités du pays
de combien coûte le le le panier de
course quand on passe à la caisse de
combien ça coûte de faire un plein
d'essence enf on avait le sentiment que
ces ministres issus de la fameuse
société civile bah en fait ils sont
surtout issus de la société aisée en
tout cas de grands postes parce qu'ils
venaient du privé et pas des des
entreprises les les plus pauvres de ce
pays qu's avaient des parcours certes
talentueux mais qui en faisaient des
gens qui étaient pas en prise avec le le
la réalité des Français or rachidti elle
porte plus ça par par son parcours parce
qu'elle a grandi dans une zone
défavorisée à Chalon surs dans un
quartier prioritaire à Chalan surs dans
une famille très nombreuse et que voilà
on connaît son son fugurant parcours de
magie puis de puis de puis de politique
et puis c'est vrai aussi d'Emmanuel
natal de le fait qu'il au ministère de
l'Éducation nationale et effec vous le
souligné c'est à ce moment-là qu'il a
éclos véritablement dans l'opinion c'est
vrai que c'est ce c'est cette manière de
parler ce Fran parler de de en fait de
parler simplement et de parler un petit
peu comme les gens et ça je pense que
enfin je trouve que ça ça contraste avec
même Emmanuel Macron je pense que quand
Emmanuel Macron parle dans beaucoup de
ses prises de parole bah en fait on on
comprend pas tout ce qu'il veut dire
quoi à mon avis pour deux raisons il y a
le en même temps déjà par qui fait qu'il
tourne souvent autour du pot que il ose
pas assumer des positions que il dit
quelque chose et puis le lendemain il va
dire son son contraire la dernière fois
il a parlé très cche c'était sur
l'affaire de pardu bon je sais pas
exactement comment c'est réussi dans
l'opinion mais en tout cas dans son camp
ça lui a occasionné pas mal de pas mal
de critiques mais sinon sur beaucoup de
sujets il équilibre beaucoup de son
discours et la deuxième raison je crois
que c'est une espèce de coquetterie
intellectuelle qui lui fait prononcer
des phrases un peu compliquées des mots
un petit peu compliqués donc on va voir
ce qu'il fait de ça demain lors de sa
conférence de presse mais je le trouve
moins audible moins compréhensible y
compris pour nous journalistes qui
tentons au quotidien de décoder le
discours politique que un Gabriel hatal
ou évidemment qu'une Rachid adati on
général quand elle parle bah oui c'est
cache ça c'est cache ouais donc demain
on va suivre la grandemère du président
de la République Mo qui l'aime bien euh
alors 3ème trè sujet que je voulais
qu'on aborde ce soir ensemble donc le
président le le le le Madame Le Pen hier
dans le jardin dans le Journal du
Dimanche a accordé une interview avec
jeandane Bardella et dans cette
interview elle dit bah moi si je deviens
présidente de la République mon premier
ministre ça sera Jordan bardellin jeune
homme qui a 28 ans qui prend la
lumière au combien qui est très haut
dans les sondages c'est une première ça
en France de dire ça comme ça aussi
facilement c'est vrai on est habitué
effectivement un ticket oui voilà on est
on est habitué au ticket anglo-saxon
mais c'est vrai que pas du tout euh pas
pas du tout en France et là
effectivement on a l'impression bah
c'est qu'elle fait un peu le parallèle
avec Macron
àal et on voit d'ailleurs les côtes de
confiance de et d'avenir de des deux
Bardella et àal sont à peu près
similaires c'est-à-dire que Jordan
Bardella ça fait pas très longtemps
qu'on le teste dans le Figaro Magazine
et pourtant il a une ascension aussi
c'est la troisè personnalité politique
aujourd'hui préférée des français donc
c'est plus que Madame Le Pen non juste
derrière Madame Le Pen d'accord prudence
de rester derrière pour l'instant la
politesse jusqu'à quand pour le moment
mais effectivement euh c'est quelqu'un
qui ces dernières années a a pris
énormément de comment dire de poids en
politique et notamment sur deux
dimensions que je trouve très
intéressantes qui sont assez
complémentaires d'ailleurs avec Marine
Le Pen c'est un sur la capacité à
prendre des décisions euh ça les
Français considère que c'est sa première
qualité et la deuxième qualité c'est
capable de rassembler au-delà de son
camp et je crois que c'est tout l'enjeu
pour le rassemblement national
évidemment on suit des données sur
l'image du rassemblement national depuis
de nombreuses années parce que je vous
ai pas précisé mais verriant c'est
l'ancien Cantard sauess oui voilà donc
il y a y a un petit historique quand
même et donc sur c'est la c'est la
première fois en décembre là qu'on a
sorti la dernière vague de ce baromètre
du de l'image du Front National et du
rassemblement national et c'est la
première fois depuis les années 80 que
le front le rassemblement national
pardon est considéré comme un parti qui
ne représente plus un danger pour la
démocratie et ce qui est un parti qui
est considéré capable que l'on considère
comme capable de gouverner un jour en
France alors que jusqu'à présent ce
n'était absolument pas le cas donc il y
a vraiment une évolution aussi à la fois
de l'opinion mais également du rapport
que l'on peut avoir au rassemblement
national
aujourd'hui pourquoi maintenant pourquoi
annoncer ce ticket maintenant à cause de
effectivement Atal je pense que alors
c'est une idée qui que le Figaro avait
révélé en septembre juste avant la
rentrée politique de Marine Le Pen et de
Jordan Bardella ou Marine Le Pen elle
avait jamais répondu à cette questionl
euh en 2000 ni en 2017 en en 2017 elle
avait dit que ça serait Nicolas dupignan
parce qu'elle avait fait un accord
politique avec lui qui serait son
premier ministre et en 2022 elle avait
pas répondu parce qu'elle nen savait pas
elleelle n'avait aucune idée et euh il y
avait une problématique vis-à-vis de
Gabriel Atal et de Marine Le Pen c'est
euh comment permettre aux Français
d'imaginer ce que pourrait être un
gouvernement ou dominé par Marine Le Pen
avec Marine Le Pen à l'ésée et un
Premier ministre qui dirigerait un
gouvernement de du RN et ben il fallait
le dire très vite aux Français qui
serait le Premier ministre plusieurs de
ses proches en tout cas pousser Marine
Le Pen à dire très vite en cas de
dissolution euh faut que tu dises au
français le plus rapidement possible qui
serait le premier ministre pour qu'il
puisse se projeter qu'on puisse il
puisse savoir un peu avoir une image de
à quoi pourrait ressembler au
gouvernement euh et donc elle a tranché
parce que Marine Le Pen là où Jordan
Bardella parfois vu par les Français
comme quelqu'un qui tranche vite Marine
Le Pen ne tranche pas très vite et là
elle a dit ok je vais dire que ça sera
Jordan Bardella qui est de toutes les
manières un peu son héritier politique
son Poulin parce qu'elle a c'est elle
qui l'a poussé dans l'arine qui l'a fait
grandir en nomant tête de liste en 2019
et là elle estime qu'il est arrivé voilà
aux européennes et qu'il est arrivé un
peu à maturation pour son âge et qu'il
faut le pousser sur une nouvelle
dimension faut dire aussi qu'il y a pas
beaucoup de choix hein dans la troupe
non dans la troupe il y a pas beaucoup
de chose c'est d'ailleurs un des
problèmes auquel se se heurte Marine Le
Pen dans les à chaque élection
présidentielle lu dit bah AC qui vous
allez gouverner c'est vrai que le le le
cheptel est pas très grand euh ce qu'il
y a aussi je pense c'est
que ils sont
complémentaires Marine Le Pen parle à à
une catégorie de Français souvent on dit
pour la
catégorie caricaturée elle est de gauche
parce que elle est beaucoup sur comme
l'a dit Paul pouir d'achat elle parle à
des catégories populaires qui l'écoute
Jordan Bardella parle à d'autres gens
euh identitaire plus
identitaire éic Zemour à un moment dans
la présentielle disait ouais mais Jordan
bardala il pourrait nous rejoindre ça a
été évidemment démenti tout ça mais on
voit bien que sur cette idée il parle à
la droite quoi globalement et donc là il
y a il y a un tandem qui peut être
complémentaire même si sous la 5e
République la dernière fois qu'il y en a
deux qui ont dit on fait un tandem comme
ça c'était de faire mades France bon ça
fait 5 % les sondage ouais elle en est
très loin puisque je reviens sur le
baromètre verriant Figaro Magazine il y
a eu un événement quand même incroyable
la semaine dernière alors c'est passé
sous silence parce que il y a eu le
remanement et que nos confrères
observateurs avaient la tête ailleurs
mais Marine Le Pen est en tête execo
avecor Philippe du baromètre sa Pantar
verriant pour la première fois je crois
on ne mesure pas ce que ça signifie
première personnalité politique première
personnalité politique sur une question
qui est très dure faites-vous confiance
pour l'avenir à cette personnalité là
Marine Le Pen ça n'était évidemment
jamais arrivé à Jean-Marie Le Pen ouais
c'est la preuve que ça a beaucoup changé
hein alors d'habitude en tête il y a
deux catégories de gens il y a les gens
qui qui ont une équation personnelle
très large Nicolas HULLOT Jacques Delord
Simon veille voilà des gens où tout le
monde se dit oui on l'aime bien
consensuel ou des gens dont une partie
de l'opinion se dit
elle lui j'aimerais bien que ça soit le
futur président de la République c'est
pour ça que à certaines époques c'est
goen royal Dominic schuskanan Nicolas
Sarkozy François Holland ont été en tête
donc là Marine Le Pen par définition
c'est pas la personnalité consensuelle
donc c'est bien la deuxème raison c'est
qu'il y a là beaucoup de de plus en plus
de français même si il faut
être honnête c'est pas elle qui monte
c'est plus or Philippe qui baisse qui
fait qu'elle elle atteint cette position
d'execo c'est quand même assez important
et elle se retrouve dans cette situation
voilà où elle est en tête du baromètre
ou une partie des Français 3 ans avant
l'échéance présidentielle se disent bah
oui on veut que ça soit elle et et et
tout ça est corrélé avec Jordan Bardella
qui est 3e les items qualitatif
finalement oui ils peuvent élargir oui
ils pourrai bien gouverner on voit bien
que là il y a une construction d'une
force d'opposition vers une force de de
majorité qui est en train de se mettre
en route Louis à l'Élysée c'est
l'opposition c'est celle-là qu'on
regarde oui avant tout oui parce que les
européennes comme celles de 2019
s'annonc comme un match entre le camp
Macron et le camp Le Pen et qu'en fait
c'est autour de ce duol que tourne toute
la vie politique nationale depuis 2017
2017 2022 à chaque fois au second tour
on a le même match et aux européennne de
2019 comme pour l'instant aux
européennes de 2024 on a également ce
match là et là-dedans il y a pas pour
l'instant de trème force il y a pas de
de on pourrait penser que après tout le
la droitisation d'Emmanuel Macron par
exemple offrirait un espace nouveau à la
gauche ou que les républicains
pourraient proposer autre chose pour
s'inter caler entre ce duel Macron Le
Pen en fait pour l'instant ça n'existe
pas il y a un duopole qui qui est
quasiment monopolistique sur sur le le
marché politique après il il y a deux
éléments alors du côté du camp Macron
c'est évidemment qu'Emmanuel Macron ne
peut pas se représenter et que à ce
titre-là le choix de Gabriel Atal donne
le premier signe qu'il a jamais donné
d'une d'une possible organisation de la
succession et ce serait là aussi une
première parce que j'ai pas souvenir on
un président de la République qui est
tenté de choisir son successeur et que
ça soit bien organisé de GA Pompidou on
peut en parler mais c'était tellement
tendu à la fin entre eux on peut pas
parler d'un successeur choisi couronné
en en grande pompe là il y a un petit
peu de ça dans la nomination de de
Gabriel Attal de la part d'un président
qui qui ne peut pas se qui ne peut pas
se représenter et du côté l'élément côté
rassemblement national alors là c'est
Carl et qui vont dire si je me trompe
mais j'ai pas souvenir qu'un président
un premier ministre soit arrivé au
pouvoir en annonçant à l'avance et
autant à l'avance quel serait le ticket
qui serait le premier ministre c'est
souvent une carte que le président
candidat enfin que le candidat à
l'élection présidentielle se garde
notamment pour les élections
législatives parce que il va devoir
composer avec une majorité dont il ne
connaît pas encore l'ampleur et la
composition et qui évidemment la carte
du Premier ministre elle est importante
pour après l'élection pas avant alors
évidemment quand Nicolas Sarkozi a fait
campagne on savait en subodoré que
François Fillon allait être son premier
ministre parce qu'il avait donné les
signaux mais ça n'a jamais été un
couronnement officiel et surtout ça
n'est pas intervenu 3 ans avant là ça va
donner en plus le le de la comment dire
de la matière pour chroniquer une
éventuelle riv ité entre Marine Le Pen
et Jordane mardella sachant que Jordane
mardella effectivement a cette force
d'aller au-delà de dans les catégories
auquel il parle d'aller au-delà de
Marine Le Pen aller concurrir des
publics qui bloquaient sur le nom de de
Marine Le Pen donc ça donne prise à la
critique même si pour l'instant que je
sache il y a pas de de rivalité il y a
pas d'AC de rivalité oui précisément
alors Paul il y a pas de rivalité entre
eux mais est-ce que Jordan Bardella
n'est pas jalousé par d'autres ah si si
il y a plusur il y a plusieurs choses
entre les deux entre Mar le et bardala
tout se passe très bien parce que le
contrat est clair euh bardala il sait
d'où il vient un peu comme Gabrielle tal
et Marie Le Pen elle sait ce qu'elle
veut faire et elle sait qu'elle a besoin
aussi d'un peu de Bardella et elle a
besoin de quelqu'un en qui elle peut
faire confiance ensuite il y a
l'entourage de Jordan Bardella et
l'entourage de Marine Le Pen ou là les
choses se passent un peu moins bien
parce que un des proches de Marine Le
Pen m'a dit une chose très juste et
peut-être un peu misogyne mais il m'a
dit c'est le syndrome de la secrétaire
qui dis que mon patron est toujours le
meilleur que celui de l'autre et donc
c'est la guerre des secrétaires entre
les deux entourages parce que chaque
entourage vérifie s'il y a pas un mot
déplacé de l'autre ils sont ils se
regardent un peu en chenfance ils sont
un peu suspicieux euh dès qu'il y a un
off qui dit que Bardella se prépare pour
une une éventuelle campagne
présidentielle même 2032 certains
imaginent que c'est veut dire qu'il
anticipe l'échec de Marine Le Pen en
2027 et donc c'est de l'antijeeu voilà
donc il y a une méfiance parce que c'est
le front ça gre quand même le Front
national même si s'appelle le
rassemblement national et la
caractéristique première de cette
famille politique c'est de se planter
des couteaux dans le dos on voit ce qui
s'est passé entre Mar maréchal Le Pen et
Marine Le Pen entre Flor Philippo Marine
Le Pen et Marion maréchal en fait c'est
l'histoire de cette famille politique là
il y a des jalousies internes parce que
Bardella mine de rien un peu comme
gabrielal en fait il grille la priorité
à toute une génération de cadres qui
accompagne Marine Le Pen ont vécu des
défaites depuis 12 ans 10 ans 12 ans
depuis qu'elle est arrivée à la tête du
rassemblement du Front Nationale je
pense à Sébastien Chenu qui est lui
arrivé en 2014 mais qui a un très proche
et qui est aujourd'hui vice-président de
l'Assemblée nationale euh c'est un
quantenaire il y en a d'autres aussi
Louis alio ancien compagnon Marine Le
Pen mais maire de pre Pignan qui lui
plus proche de l'âge Marine Le Pen et
donc voilà Bardella grâce à la volonté
de Marine Le Pen est en train de doubler
toute cette génération de cadres et lui
en tout cas se prépare aussi à exercer
le pouvoir soit à matigon et Marine Le
Pen le dit souvent aussi elle dit
qu'elle est la candidate naturelle de
son camp euh tant que le contraire n'est
pas prouvé mais en off elle dit elle
explique aussi on sait pas ce qui peut
m'arriver d'ici 3 ans je peux avoir un
accident grave de la vie je peux avoir
une condamnation en justice et une
condamnation en éligibilité avec
l'affaire notamment des des assistants
parlementaires européens on a on attend
quand le le procès commence en septembre
octobre 2024 2024 donc dans moins d'un
an elle ce qu'elle regarde c'est surtout
ce que ce qui va se passer pour François
berou qui a à peu près le même procès
avec la même enquête qui a eu lieu et là
il attend le jugement donc on verra s'il
y a une estime qu'on on verra s'il y a
une Clémence ou nom des juges comment en
tout cas la la justice va trancher ce ce
caslà elle fera évidemment si elle
condamné elle fera elle fera appel mais
voilà elle a
dit j'ai besoin d'avoir un homme de
confiance déjà à matigon les Français
ont besoin de savoir à quoi pourrait
ressembler un gouvernement du du RN
parce qu'en fait jusqu'à présent c'était
inenvisageable et qu'en fait on arrive
dans une espèce de politique fiction
qu'il faut autoalimenter qui nous
permettra d'accéder au pouvoir voilà
merci ben je crois qu'on a fait le tour
de la question en tous les cas de
quelques questions trois questions
qui se posait aujourd'hui demain on va
regarder avec attention le président de
la
République et puis on va se retrouver la
semaine prochaine je suis persuadé qu'on
parlera évidemment des mêmes
sujets avec peut-être un peu plus de
d'angle d'attaque en fonction de ce que
le président de la République nous aura
dit demain voilà je vous souhaite une
très bonne nuit et je vous propose de se
retrouver de nous retrouver